Bienvenue dans ce nouvel épisode de l'informatique quantique en pratique. Cet épisode va se concentrer sur la première, et souvent la plus
difficile, des étapes dans la définition d'un programme quantique : mapper un problème général sur un circuit qui peut s'exécuter sur un ordinateur
quantique. Cette étape décrit comment un utilisateur, partant d'un problème
computationnel donné, peut le traduire pour qu'un ordinateur quantique puisse le comprendre.
Dans les leçons précédentes de cette série, les leçons deux et trois, on a vu que l'étape de mapping est la première étape sur
les quatre du framework Qiskit patterns. À partir de ces leçons, tu te souviens peut-être que notre objectif était de traduire
ou réécrire un problème computationnel sous la forme d'une fonction de coût ou d'une valeur d'espérance
que l'on peut évaluer à l'aide d'un ordinateur quantique.
Dans la leçon trois, on a vu un exemple concret avec le max cut, un problème
qui est difficile sur le plan computationnel et qui est courant en optimisation combinatoire.
Dans cet exemple, on a suivi plusieurs étapes pour transformer le graphe initial en un problème natif quantique. On a
transformé le problème de la recherche du nombre maximum de coupes dans le graphe en une fonction de coût, puis réécrit cette fonction de coût
sous la forme d'un Hamiltonien et préparé un état quantique d'essai dont l'état fondamental
correspond au max cut. Enfin, on a construit un circuit quantique représentant l'état quantique d'essai
d'intérêt, puis ajouté les gate spécifiques pour permettre à l'état d'évoluer dans le temps. Cette séquence d'étapes, c'est ce qu'on
appelle le mapping. Et à un niveau général, la procédure s'applique à de nombreuses autres applications comme la chimie quantique
et la simulation quantique. Il faut reconnaître que le mapping peut être difficile. Il n'existe pas de
stratégie universelle pour chaque problème, ce qui peut être intimidant. Aujourd'hui, je vais mettre en avant
quelques exemples représentatifs de différents problèmes et décrire comment ils ont été mappés dans chaque cas. Je vais rapidement
récapituler ce qu'on a appris sur les problèmes de graphes comme ceux utilisés dans le Max Cut et passer le reste du cours à me concentrer
sur la façon de mapper des problèmes qui apparaissent dans la nature, comme les problèmes de structure moléculaire en biologie, les
problèmes de structure électronique en chimie et la simulation des théories quantiques des champs en physique des hautes énergies.
Mais avant de passer la majeure partie de cet épisode à regarder des exemples de problèmes tirés de la littérature, je veux te donner
un aperçu général des principales choses qu'on veut accomplir et considérer quand on mappe un problème. Il y a
quelques éléments à prendre en compte pour tout type de problème computationnel qui devra être traduit en circuit quantique.
Premièrement, tu pourrais avoir besoin de simplifier le problème pour le rendre faisable. C'est quelque chose de courant dans la plupart des disciplines scientifiques.
Ce n'est pas propre à l'informatique quantique. Si tu as déjà entendu l'expression « supposons une
vache sphérique », elle fait allusion au fait qu'il est souvent difficile de décrire un système exactement tel qu'il apparaît. Mais
à la place, on peut faire des simplifications raisonnables qui peuvent quand même mener à des solutions utiles.
Quelques exemples de la façon dont on pourrait faire ça en informatique quantique : limiter la taille ou la profondeur du circuit en choisissant un
ansatz efficace pour le hardware, ou tronquer des évolutions temporelles complexes, ou négliger
des termes du Hamiltonien qui contribuent peu à l'énergie finale d'un état quantique.
Le point suivant que je veux souligner, c'est que tu vas devoir réfléchir à la façon d'écrire le problème de manière à ce qu'un ordinateur quantique puisse en avoir du sens.
Souvent, ça implique de se poser ces trois questions. Un : qu'est-ce que nos qubit
vont représenter dans ce modèle ? Deux : notre problème est-il continu ? Comme les ordinateurs quantiques sont numériques, tu vas devoir
trouver un moyen de discrétiser le problème. Et trois, dernièrement : la topologie du problème s'aligne-t-elle avec la topologie du
hardware ? Si oui, c'est parfait. Mais sinon, il faudra peut-être mettre en œuvre quelques astuces pour y remédier. Alors abordons
cette première question. Ce qui est, je pense, au cœur de toutes les difficultés à comprendre le mapping, surtout en tant que
nouveau concept. Qu'est-ce qu'un qubit peut représenter ?
Les qubit peuvent être utilisés pour représenter beaucoup de choses. La première et la plus simple, à mon avis, c'est un nœud sur un graphe. Les graphes sont
utilisés pour montrer la connectivité dans de nombreux types de problèmes mathématiques. Et les nœuds sont un élément fondamental représentant un point
ou une entité au sein d'un réseau. Selon ce que représente l'ensemble du réseau, ça pourrait être une ville, une personne ou un
ferromagnétique dans un réseau. Les qubit peuvent aussi être utilisés pour représenter des bzons et des firmions. Bien que je te mette en garde ici
qu'un seul qubit n'équivaut pas exactement à un boson ou à un firmion. C'est un peu
plus compliqué que ça et j'y reviendrai bientôt, mais en général, une chaîne de spins qui suit certaines statistiques est
quelque chose qui peut être facilement traduit en architecture de qubit.
Maintenant, on entre dans des exemples un peu plus compliqués. Pour ces modèles, il n'est plus logique de
parler en termes d'un seul qubit.
Il faut plutôt des groupes d'entre eux pour former quelque chose de physique. Par exemple, un
groupe de qubit représenté ici sur une topologie hexagonale lourde peut être utilisé pour représenter des emplacements géométriques d'acides aminés
ou de chaînes polymères. Un autre exemple est la simulation de la diffusion de hadrons
dans des modèles de physique des hautes énergies, ce qui peut se faire en simulant l'évolution temporelle d'un paquet d'ondes hadronique. Dans ce cas,
un registre de qubit peut être utilisé pour encoder différents états d'un champ quantique. L'état du vide de ce champ ou
un paquet d'ondes qui se propage au-dessus de ce vide.
Je veux également noter que le mapping du problème sur un ordinateur quantique comporte des étapes distinctes, à savoir : premièrement, mapper les
états sur des qubit et des circuit, et deuxièmement, mapper la fonction de coût ou l'espérance
des observables et opérateurs quantiques. On verra comment ceux-ci sont traités dans des exemples spécifiques. Mais à
ce stade, on a parlé de façon assez abstraite du défi qui nous attend.
Voyons maintenant ces exemples en détail.
Commençons par notre premier exemple. À mon avis, l'un des problèmes de mapping les plus faciles est celui qu'on a déjà
vu en profondeur, l'exemple du max cut. Dans ce problème, le mapping était assez simple pour nous parce qu'un qubit
WEBVTT
équivalait à un nœud sur notre graphe. Utiliser des nœuds sur un graphe est très intuitif, et c'est
une chance, car ça correspond à de nombreuses applications. Souvent, quand tu veux modéliser quelque chose qui correspond à une
série de nœuds connectés entre eux, si les regroupements sont binaires comme zéro ou un, ou inclus et non inclus dans un
ensemble, tu peux simplement et naturellement mapper ces nœuds en bits ou en qubit.
Dans cet exemple, et même dans celui qu'on a mis à l'échelle jusqu'à 100 qubit dans l'épisode 3, la connectivité du graphe
correspondait déjà à la topologie de notre hardware supraconducteur. On n'avait donc pas besoin de s'en préoccuper non plus. Mais ce n'est pas toujours le cas.
Et si tu as un graphe plus complexe ou plus connecté que les exemples qu'on a mis en avant jusqu'ici, tu vas
devoir implémenter des swap gate. Mais ça est en fait géré à la deuxième étape des Qiskit patterns, qui concerne
la transpilation. L'autre aspect du problème du max cut qui le rend si pratique, c'est qu'on
sait déjà exprimer la fonction de coût comme un Hamiltonien en utilisant la formulation QUBO.
Rappelle-toi qu'en informatique quantique et dans les algorithmes quantiques variationnels, une fonction de coût Hamiltonien est une fonction
qui encode la solution optimale du problème dans l'état fondamental du Hamiltonien.
Pour construire le Hamiltonien de coût, on a pu utiliser la classe sparse poly op dans Qiskit pour spécifier la
connectivité de notre graphe, et l'étape de mapping vers les opérateurs quantiques est faite. Et le circuit quantique était
simplement l'ansatz QAOA. Si ça ne te rappelle rien, reviens voir l'épisode 3 où on passe
tout ça en détail. Maintenant, augmentons légèrement la difficulté. On va ensuite regarder
un exemple modélisé dans l'article intitulé « Resource-efficient quantum algorithm for protein folding » écrit par
IBM en collaboration avec l'University of New South Wales. Un peu de contexte en biochimie. Les protéines sont
des macromolécules composées de longues chaînes d'acides aminés. Ces longues chaînes se replient
en structures complexes qui accomplissent une grande variété de fonctions biologiques.
Déterminer la structure d'une protéine dans un espace tridimensionnel et comprendre les relations entre
la structure et la fonction comptent parmi les problèmes les plus difficiles en biochimie aujourd'hui.
Les protéines se replient en structures utiles en raison des interactions entre les acides aminés eux-mêmes.
Lorsque la structure se tord et se replie, des acides aminés éloignés les uns des autres sur la chaîne peuvent se retrouver côte à côte
et interagir fortement. On a besoin d'un Hamiltonien décrivant toutes ces interactions entre les acides
aminés si on veut prédire quelle structure finale minimisera l'énergie. On va se concentrer sur les chaînes d'acides aminés et
sur la façon dont elles peuvent être modélisées sur un ordinateur quantique, puis sur la façon d'obtenir les distances inter-acides aminés pour
le calcul des énergies d'interaction.
Avec ça, on aura réuni toutes les contributions nécessaires au Hamiltonien pour le simuler
sur un ordinateur quantique. Dans les vraies protéines, les acides aminés peuvent occuper un continuum d'emplacements possibles.
Cependant, on va utiliser une simplification ici et les restreindre à un modèle de réseau où chaque acide aminé
occupe un point sur une grille. Ici, les auteurs ont utilisé un réseau tétraédrique.
Note rapide : on encode ici la direction des arêtes, et non les nœuds eux-mêmes comme dans le problème du max cut.
Chaque qubit représente un chemin possible d'une étape le long de la grille tétraédrique. Note que les sites adjacents ont
été étiquetés A ou B dans ce diagramme en raison de leurs différentes orientations dans le réseau.
La chaîne protéique est représentée comme une série de virages ou de directions sur ce
réseau. Chaque virage entre les acides aminés peut se faire dans l'une des quatre directions
correspondant aux arêtes du tétraèdre.
Ces quatre virages possibles sont encodés à l'aide de quatre qubit.
Ça paraît un peu compliqué. Regardons donc cet exemple plus en détail.
Plaçons notre première chaîne d'acides aminés sur ce point dans le réseau tétraédrique. La direction vers le premier
acide aminé en direction du second est arbitraire, car on peut toujours faire pivoter le système pour que cette arête pointe
dans n'importe quelle direction qu'on veut. Donc plaçons notre deuxième acide aminé ici. Ce n'est pas aussi
facile à voir, mais le chemin du second au troisième est en réalité lui aussi arbitraire. Les trois choix donneraient
comme résultat deux arêtes faisant un angle d'environ 109,5°
l'une par rapport à l'autre. Choisir cette deuxième arête détermine simplement l'orientation de notre protéine dans l'espace. Donc sans perte de
généralité du tout, on peut choisir que les premiers virages soient simplement 0 0 1 et 0 0 1
0. Avec ces simplifications, la configuration de la chaîne d'acides aminés est simplement donnée par cette expression.
Jusqu'ici, on a mappé les arêtes du tétraèdre sur des qubit et notre circuit quantique sera un ansatz. On a maintenant besoin de
réfléchir à la façon d'encoder l'énergie du problème dans un Hamiltonien afin que son état fondamental nous donne le
schéma de repliement optimal. Pour toute configuration donnée, il y aura une énergie associée due aux
interactions entre les acides aminés eux-mêmes. Ces interactions sont les plus fortes quand les deux acides aminés sont
proches l'un de l'autre. Évidemment, les acides aminés qui sont adjacents dans le squelette de la chaîne interagiront toujours
entre eux. Mais parce que la protéine peut se tordre et se replier, d'autres paires d'acides aminés
peuvent aussi interagir. Les acides aminés 10 et 20, par exemple, pourraient se retrouver sur des
sites adjacents après le repliement de la protéine. Les acides aminés qui se retrouvent proches les uns des autres ont des interactions
plus fortes et dirigent le processus de repliement, mais ils n'ont pas nécessairement des indices proches les uns des
autres. On a donc besoin d'une formule pour décrire la distance D entre les acides aminés I et
J en utilisant l'information encodée sur les qubit de configuration. De cette façon, on peut
utiliser leur distance de séparation pour déterminer l'intensité de leurs interactions. C'est un peu compliqué,
mais reste avec moi, parce que c'est une astuce ingénieuse. D'abord, introduisons une fonction f sous a de i qui indique si oui ou
WEBVTT
non une arête a est utilisée pour le virage à l'acide aminé i. Ici, a peut prendre n'importe laquelle
des quatre directions possibles selon le codage de configuration ci-dessus. On peut écrire ces fonctions, puis
définir une différence dans le nombre de virages étiquetés a sur les réseaux A et B de
l'indice I à l'indice J comme delta N. Pourquoi ferait-on ça ? Eh bien, il s'avère que le
réseau tétraédrique possède une propriété très utile. Concentrons-nous sur cet acide aminé ici. Peu importe lequel il s'agit,
mais appelons-le l'acide aminé E. On veut savoir à quelle distance se trouvera l'acide aminé j. Et tout ce qu'on a,
ce sont les arêtes le long desquelles le squelette avance. En partant de I, note qu'un pas
depuis le centre le long d'un type d'arête particulier, appelons-le a, depuis ce site de réseau a
est exactement opposé et est annulé par un pas le long de l'arête a depuis les
sites b. Donc plusieurs pas le long de l'arête A depuis n'importe quel site de réseau A éloigne
le squelette de l'acide aminé E, et les pas le long du type d'arête A depuis les sites B
te ramènent. Donc la distance entre deux acides aminés I et J le long du type
d'arête qu'on appellera A dépend de la différence entre les pas effectués le long des arêtes A
depuis les sites A et les sites B. Puisque A et B alternent nécessairement dans le
squelette protéique, ceci est capturé par le terme moins 1 à la puissance K. Et cet argument s'applique aussi aux autres types d'arêtes
également. Donc la distance entre les acides aminés dans les pas du réseau tétraédrique peut être calculée au final par cette
expression. Mais comment obtenir le Hamiltonien à partir de cette longue équation pour la distance totale entre les acides aminés ? Il y a
en réalité une correspondance biunivoque entre ces distances dans les pas du réseau tétraédrique et la distance
euclidienne. Et tu peux voir que j'ai déjà calculé certaines des expressions pour toi.
Ces distances peuvent être utilisées pour calculer l'énergie de ta configuration.
Selon ton objectif, tu pourrais imposer une distance de coupure en dessous de laquelle tu considères que la paire interagit,
ou tu pourrais faire quelque chose de plus compliqué. Ce n'est peut-être pas évident, mais on a en réalité terminé l'étape de mapping
en faisant ça. Les états des qubit indiquent le virage, et l'ensemble des virages dicte la
distance entre chaque paire d'acides aminés. Les paires de diverses espèces d'acides
aminés ont des interactions différentes, certaines attractives, certaines répulsives. Si tu utilises la configuration et la distance pour
simplement déterminer si des interactions entre acides aminés connus sont actives ou inactives, les
intensités de celles-ci sont bien connues. Pas par moi, mais tu peux les chercher dans un tableau comme celui-ci. Donc en résumé, dans
cet exemple, les qubit sont utilisés pour marquer des emplacements sur un réseau qui forment ensemble une chaîne d'acides aminés.
Et en simulant la façon dont ils se plient et se replient, on peut espérer trouver de meilleurs résultats dans la recherche médicale. On a
sauté le calcul de quelques termes de ce Hamiltonien parce qu'ils étaient très spécifiques à ce problème. Tandis que définir
des directions sur un réseau peut s'appliquer de façon plus générale.
Une fois que tu as un Hamiltonien général, tu vas toujours vouloir le traduire en opérateurs de Pauli qui sont
natifs à l'ordinateur quantique. C'est ce dont on parlera ensuite.
Continuons. Explorons maintenant comment traduire un système de particules subatomiques en opérateurs de Pauli. Les particules subatomiques
sont réparties en deux catégories : les bzons et les firmions. Les bzons,
comme les photons ou le boson de Higgs, obéissent à un certain ensemble de règles statistiques, et les firmions, comme les électrons ou les neutrinos, obéissent à un autre.
La différence essentielle entre eux est que les bzons peuvent occuper le même état. Il n'y a pas de limite au nombre de
bzons qui peuvent se trouver dans l'état fondamental ou dans tout autre état excité. Les fermions, en revanche, sont égoïstes. Ils exigent que
chaque particule ait son propre état quantique. Les bzons ont aussi des spins entiers tandis que les firmions ont des spins demi-entiers
comme l'électron de spin 1/2 ou des particules de spin 3/2 plus exotiques. Pour
décrire un système de particules, on a besoin d'une description de leur énergie. Concentrons-nous sur les firmions. On peut commencer par le
Hamiltonien écrit en termes de ce qu'on appelle les opérateurs C. Ce sont essentiellement des objets mathématiques qui
correspondent à la création ou à l'annihilation d'un firmion depuis un état du système.
Ceux-ci sont souvent écrits comme fi dague et fi dans une notation qu'on appelle seconde
quantification. Maintenant, fi dague est l'opérateur qui crée un firmion dans l'état i. Fi est
l'opérateur qui détruit un firmion dans l'état i. Mais rappelle-toi que les ordinateurs quantiques fonctionnent généralement dans une base de qubit
avec des règles spécifiques pour représenter les systèmes fermioniques. Ils ne fonctionnent pas inheremment dans le langage des
opérateurs fermioniques. Pour combler ce fossé, on a besoin de mapper la notation de seconde quantification en opérateurs de Pauli qui
correspondent naturellement aux gate quantiques.
Il existe plusieurs transformations de ce type pour les firmions. Un choix courant est la transformation de Jordan-Wigner.
Les mappings de Bravyi-Kitaev et de parité sont plus récents pour les encodages fermioniques.
Les opérations bzoniques, en revanche, peuvent être transformées en utilisant la transformation de Holstein-Primakoff ou en mappant directement
les états de Fock sur une sous-base des modes bzoniques disponibles.
Et il y a aussi d'autres options pour les bzons. D'autres encodages sont également activement étudiés. Mais pour l'instant,
on va juste se concentrer sur la transformation de Jordan-Wigner.
Alors pourquoi ne pas simplement assigner un qubit pour représenter chaque électron ? Eh bien, on ne peut pas.
Les qubit sont discernables et les électrons ne le sont pas. Par exemple, on peut facilement étiqueter et identifier des qubit individuels sur
n'importe quel appareil, mais l'indiscernabilité des électrons signifie qu'on ne peut pas les étiqueter du tout. On a en fait besoin d'étiqueter
à la place les opérateurs selon les orbitales occupées comme 1s, 2s et 2p
plutôt que des électrons spécifiques. On a donc en réalité besoin d'étiqueter les opérateurs selon les orbitales occupées comme 1s
2s et 2p plutôt que d'étiqueter des électrons spécifiques. Ainsi, chaque qubit joue
WEBVTT
approximativement le rôle d'une orbitale dans la molécule, qui est soit occupée soit inoccupée.
Mais la façon dont on fait ça est en réalité un peu plus compliquée. On introduit donc maintenant quelque chose qu'on appelle le mapping de Jordan-Wigner pour garder la trace de
l'antisymétrie et s'assurer que les statistiques correctes du système fermionique global sont respectées. Le mapping de Jordan-
Wigner est conceptuellement simple en raison de la corrélation un-pour-un entre les orbitales et les qubit. Il y a
d'autres mappings qui atteignent un objectif similaire, dont le mapping de parité.
Le calcul de la parité d'un état nécessite de considérer plusieurs qubit. Dans le mapping de parité et certains autres, l'
interprétation d'un qubit correspondant à une orbitale ne tient pas.
Parcourons maintenant ensemble un exemple assez simple pour nous assurer qu'on maîtrise cette transformation.
Supposons qu'on veuille calculer l'interaction à un seul qubit f dague f. On commence par substituer nos définitions pour les
opérateurs de montée et de descente. On peut ensuite regrouper les termes en factorisant la matrice identité i et le 1/4.
Comme on le voit, on se retrouve avec des termes qui sembleront familiers à ceux qui traitent des relations de commutation. Ce terme ici dans
la parenthèse n'est rien d'autre que i multiplié par le commutateur de x zéro et y. Et n'
oublie pas l'identité qu'on a sortie.
Rappelle-toi que ce sont juste des matrices de Pauli. Ainsi, le commutateur est bien connu. Le commutateur de x et y dans
cet ordre est simple. C'est 2 i z. Fais attention à ne pas perdre la trace de tes signes négatifs et tu obtiendras ceci comme résultat final.
Au final, on a réécrit avec succès une expression fermionique
en termes d'opérateurs de Pauli que notre ordinateur quantique sera capable de comprendre.
Voyons rapidement comment on implémenterait le mapping de Jordan-Wigner dans Qiskit, parce que bien que je pense qu'il est
important de comprendre comment le mapping et les transformations similaires fonctionnent et de le voir détaillé au moins une fois, tu
ne voudrais pas avoir à faire tout ce travail manuellement à chaque fois.
Surtout pour les systèmes de grande taille en particulier, on peut utiliser la fonction sparse poly op dans Qiskit pour
créer facilement les opérations de Pauli associées à partir d'un mapping. Une implémentation non optimale
utilisera des boucles imbriquées et prend environ 20 lignes de code.
Je vais mettre le code ici pour que vous puissiez tous l'explorer. Mais à un niveau général, les étapes sont les suivantes.
Un, utiliser la fonction sparse poly ops from list pour créer un opérateur identité
correspondant à la taille de l'espace des paramètres à mapper. Deux, en suivant la définition des opérateurs de création
et d'annihilation montrés précédemment, utiliser la fonction sparse polyops from list pour définir les opérations de Pauli x, y et z.
Ceci mappera les opérateurs de création et d'annihilation fermioniques sur des opérateurs de spin de qubit encodant le nombre d'occupation fermionique
dans la base computationnelle des qubit, et trois, générer le
Hamiltonien désiré dans la base de Pauli en appliquant les opérateurs ci-dessus aux orbitales d'intérêt. Cela correspond généralement à la
création d'une matrice identité qui représente le cœur, les orbitales non interagissantes, puis à l'application des opérateurs de création
et d'annihilation à l'espace actif avec des poids qui correspondent aux spécificités du problème en question. Comme
je l'ai mentionné, c'est juste une décomposition de haut niveau. Le code n'est cependant pas trop compliqué, et tu devrais maintenant
te sentir confiant pour l'adapter à d'autres problèmes d'intérêt.
Maintenant qu'on comprend pleinement le schéma de mapping de Jordan-Wigner, voyons-le en action dans une configuration plus complexe. Tu
te souviens peut-être de cet article d'un épisode précédent sur la dynamique des hadrons. Je ne vais pas le revoir en détail, mais vérifie
l'épisode précédent si tu l'as manqué et que tu es curieux. Dans cet exemple, le mapping de Jordan-Wigner est utilisé pour
exprimer le Hamiltonien de sites de réseau avec L sites pour le modèle de Schwinger en l'absence d'un champ électrique. Ici,
il est beaucoup plus difficile de déterminer précisément ce qu'un qubit représente dans ce modèle car c'est seulement
l'ensemble des qubit qui forme quelque chose de physique. Dans ce contexte, un paquet d'ondes. Tu peux plutôt
penser grossièrement aux qubit comme des morceaux discrétisés d'espace où L est le volume du réseau dans lequel chaque élément ou
cellule unitaire comprend deux qubit. Les opérateurs fermioniques qu'on a vus dans la diapositive précédente décrivent l'amplitude de
la fonction d'onde sur un site particulier.
Notre Hamiltonien contient donc ces opérateurs de montée et de descente fermioniques. Mais pour implémenter un tel
Hamiltonien sur un ordinateur quantique, on aura besoin de l'exprimer en termes d'opérateurs de spin, pas les opérateurs fermioniques.
On utilise donc la transformation de Jordan-Wigner. Après avoir appliqué la transformation de Jordan-Wigner, notre nouveau
Hamiltonien devient cette équation au bas de la diapositive où sigma plus est l'opérateur de Pauli X + I Y et sigma
moins est X - IY. Une fois qu'on a un Hamiltonien écrit dans ce format, la
partie difficile d'une étape de mapping est terminée et il peut maintenant être facilement écrit dans un circuit en opérateurs de Pauli.
En résumé, on a discuté de quatre exemples de la façon dont des techniques de mapping spécifiques ont été utilisées récemment dans le
domaine de l'informatique quantique. En partant du plus simple et en montant jusqu'à l'application de la transformation de Jordan-Wigner à la
dynamique des Hadamard. Je réalise que c'est beaucoup. Ce matériel était très technique
et si tu ne l'as pas vu avant, ça peut être très intimidant. La bonne nouvelle, c'est que je te promets que ça devient plus facile et plus
familier au fur et à mesure que tu passes du temps à pratiquer. Et c'est vraiment l'enjeu, et c'est pourquoi j'ai nommé toute la
série Quantum Computing in Practice.
Ce n'est pas quelque chose que quelqu'un peut simplement prendre en main et faire tourner depuis le début. Ça nécessite un peu d'étude, de
réflexion, et probablement des moments frustrants. Mais je t'encourage à rester avec l'inconfort et à
vraiment explorer les questions qui se posent au fur et à mesure que tu continues, car c'est la seule façon de vraiment apprendre. Merci
d'avoir regardé. C'était l'épisode 5 de quantum computing in practice. La prochaine fois, on va explorer comment simuler
un Hamiltonien from scratch. À bientôt.